I was doing a lot of rescue work I was a
peace officer for the state of New York
for the league for animal protection
voluntary I got no pay for it but I had
to carry a gun 24 hours I had a badge
and I would go out and investigate
animal abuse and and wow a quick story I
remember going getting called into where
a dog was being really abused the
Pitbull was being really abused uh at
this at this location somewhere on Long
Island I'm not going to give you the
location so I go there about 10 11
o'clock at night I knock on the door
needs to be grubby looking guys to
answer the door right out of a biker
movie and they say yeah what do you want
they said well I got a complaint about
your uh your dog being abused and he
said who are you and I said I'm with the
animal league for protection he said
you're a dog cop
you're a dog huh so then then and it was
it was a motorcycle gang I'll mention
their name with the pagans but a big
Club on the East Coast very very
aggressive club and we started talking
and I was in the military and after that
confrontation we started smoking a joint
together I trained the dog we became
good friends but
it was all worked out it all worked out
but so I started getting a little
notoriety you know I started training
some mobster's dogs you know Carlo
Gambino in a lot of ways Gambino's dogs
yeah yeah I mean weren't you why would
you take that job let me tell you
Michael I knew who I was training I knew
who Carlo Gambino was by the time I
trained his dog that dog was cooking
pasta and speaking Italian no doubt mom
but here's what happened is once you
train or once you work with a monster
either as their lawyer as their
accountant their doctor they all only
use the same doctor so I became like the
the one to the the mob it was it's kind
of interesting
um Henry Hill you know Henry Hills he
was the Ray Ray Liotta played Henry Hill
in uh Goodfellas yeah I was at his house
when he was counting
hundred dollar bills with these cash
machines I was working in that Hill oh
yeah I worked with his dog
and one of my closest friends Nico who
you remember yeah part of his house yeah
and so so I got to work with all these
monsters and again are they nice to you
yeah you know what did you ever see
anything that was like oh any
moments where you just go
I bet there's a dead body here I didn't
think of a dead body because I I pull up
the to the uh Brownstone house in uh in
uh
Brownsville Brooklyn a real sleazy
neighborhood so I'm going to train this
dog and I pull up to the house and I go
to the front and this two big guys
standing right out of a movie I mean
Hawaiian shirts the whole bit Michael
right out of a movie so I walk and they
say who you I said hold on name's Warren
next time you gotta train the dog
and they said what the organizer
whoever's on the dog so they had a
Neapolitan mass of an Italian dog so
they let me go downstairs into this this
basement apartment
to meet the guy who owned the dog and
I'm looking around and I'm looking
around I say what looks different here
there's like 20 telephones and desks
over there there's another 20 telephones
and desks over there and I'm saying to
myself it doesn't look like they're
raising money for muscular dystrophy
over here it was a bookie joint they
were just taking all these calls in they
were always nice to me uh they always
paid cash no contracts uh but quite
honestly they paid you well oh and they
did pay well absolutely this is a quick
story about one of the real big monsters
I just married Faye
maybe a year and we were poor so we
would sit and eat dinner on the floor we
had no dining room table we lived in a
studio apartment in Long Beach not too
far from where you lived yeah so the
bottom line was I would get to know this
guy Walter who was The Bodyguard for
this this major mobster and he would
talk to me and after six or eight weeks
of working with the dog we get to know
each other and they said there's one
thing what would you want you know I
would love to have a dinette set for me
and my wife so we don't have to eat on
the floor so I finished training his dog
they were real happy with it the day I
left they gave me an envelope and said
do it I didn't open the envelope in
front of him I got into my car my 1970
duster got into my car opened the
envelope and it was a check there
another check that was cashed it for 500
and a note that says go buy that dinette
set
and you did I did so yeah they were they
were really nice to work with I listen I
don't admire what they did on the other
side of course but in terms of going to
the homes and working with their dogs I
never had any problems with any